Before we begin,
I have to make a true confession to you
in my class or my class and I have been
confessing things all semester,
but this is the,
I basically set myself up for this failure
and then realized at the end of the
class someone came to me and asked me
a question and then I realized, okay,
so remember how I told you how at
Uva for like five straight years,
I forgot Thomas Jefferson's birthday
even though everything closed. Yeah.
Guess what I didn't say on Tuesday,
I forgot it was Thomas
Jefferson's Brooklyn.
I like completely forgot something
came up at the end and said, well,
in honor of Jefferson's birthday we
did the following and I was like,
so it's good to know that
I'm really consistently a
horrible Uva Grad who always
forgets Thomas Jefferson's birthday. It
must be like a Hamiltonian mental block.
Good. I like, it is not possible for
me to keep that date in my head anyway.
I at least wanted to say happy
birthday John, with you ever since.
So now officially I'm a little late,
but he'll get over it. So anyway, I've,
I've confessed to you. I feel
much better now. Okay. Um,
so today we turned to the constitution,
um,
in the last few lectures
and in today's lecture, um,
basically we've been looking at the new
nation figure out its shape and form,
right?
What,
what kind of a nation is going to be as
people were discovering throughout the
seventies and eighties,
it was one thing to protest against things
that you didn't like in a government
as the Americans had
during the revolution.
It was quite another thing to come up
with an alternative to come up with
something better and then
to get others to agree.
Today's lecture,
I'm sorry,
Tuesday's lecture discuss part of this
process of figuring out the shape and
form of the new nation. So we looked
at the Mount Vernon conference,
we looked at the Annapolis
convention and we, in doing that,
we're looking at a gradual process that
was unfolding one step at a time with no
inevitable outcome.
So basically what we saw on Tuesday was
how the Americans are basically backing
their way into what would become
the constitutional convention.
So it's not as though everyone said,
hey,
we need a new constitution and it's
gotta be stronger. Let's go right there.
It's a process. It which people are
really figuring things out as they go,
and today I want to stress that same
message that the constitution was not
inevitable and I know that's obvious
on the one hand, but on the other hand,
it's so ingrained in us, I think to think
that it's a great idea that of course,
what happens sooner or later that I feel
the need at the outset of the lecture
to say this,
that obviously it was not inevitable.
We think to ourselves,
well of course the articles,
what a goofy government the
articles of confederation was.
Of course they've got to come
up with something better.
Of course it's going to be stronger.
Of course it's going to end up
looking like our constitution.
And obviously the problem with that
whole river of of courses is that if he
traveled down that stream,
you miss one of the most important
aspects of the process of creating the
constitution.
And that is that it was a
process that it was a debate.
It was a national debate during which
people really seriously considered what
they were doing, what the implications
were of what they were doing.
And they did not all agree on
what was a good or a bad idea.
So the process,
the fact that there actually was a debate
is significant and it's not a process
that was entirely disconnected
from the revolution,
the things that Americans had been yelling
about during the revolution. Right?
They talked in a variety of
different ways about liberties.
They talked in a variety of different
ways about rights that wasn't just
rhetoric.
People were truly arguing about and
defending specific fundamental rights and
privileges that they felt they
deserved as British subjects.
And of course the end result about
that fight was the revolution.
So now we're years later and we're
looking at arguments over a new form of
government and some of these things,
same things are being yelled about.
So as you're going to see in
the course of today's lecture,
I'm in one way or another,
people are still fretting about sort
of what they consider to be fundamental
liberties,
basic rights.
People consider these things to be the
legacy of the revolution and they didn't
want to give them away before they
even really begun to enjoy them.
So think back for a minute, many moons
ago, it's so long ago in this semester,
but think back to when we were talking
about the vote for independence and I
mentioned Pauline Mayer's book.
Um,
and I talked about how in her book she
has a chapter in which he talks about the
other declarations of independence and
she really shows how on a local level
people were getting together and
debating as groups in towns and counties.
What do you think about independence
and should we actually support this?
That that was actually a real debate.
And what I'm talking about here,
what I will be talking about
over the course of this lecture,
it's a similar process of debate in
which people throughout the country,
we're really trying to figure something
out. They knew it was a major decision.
They were hoping whatever it was going
to happen was going to be a smart
decision.
But it's an actual debate.
And along these lines, as you'll
see by the end of today's lecture,
this is not the kind of lecture in which
I'm going to give you this deep textual
analysis of the constitution.
Um,
basically I've got this lecture and a
little bit in the next lecture to talk
about the constitution.
I'm sure the founders are spinning
in their graves like what,
45 minutes to get to the constitution.
Um,
but that's where we are in the semester.
given that I only have
that amount of time,
what I really want to focus on is the
process of creating the constitution.
And in doing that,
I'm also going to talk about a handful
of ongoing controversies that we have
seen before during the revolution
at an earlier part of this course.
And we're going to see them again towards
the end of this lecture when we focus
on some of the main areas that became
controversies for the constitutional
convention. Now, I think in the same
way that we have all these of courses,
you know, of course we know what's
going to happen. It's the constitution.
I think it's also easy for us to
walk down the, of course trail,
when we think about nationalists like
James Madison or Alexander Hamilton on
some sort of basic level, we assume, well
they're right or they're the smart guys,
they are right and anyone who is against
them. It's sort of a short sided,
limited minded person who like clearly
isn't thinking on a broad, smart level.
Right? I think almost instinctively
because we think what we think about our
constitution, we think that way about
whoever supported it or did not.
Now certainly these nationalists felt
like they were vindicating the revolution,
right?
So if you'd asked them,
they would have told you that they felt
they were preserving the achievements of
the revolution.
They were fending off chaos and a variety
of other things that would defeat what
had been one in the revolution. And from
our vantage point, we can look back.
We see that and that makes sense.
But this wasn't the only argument
that was circulating at the time.
So even before the
constitutional convention met,
people have valid fears about
what might result from it.
And they were fears that were strong
enough that some people didn't even think
they're states should participate
in the convention. Nevermind.
Like arguing about ratification.
I'm backing is way up.
There were many people who just thought,
I don't want to,
I don't think our state should participate
in this whole idea of revising the
government in some way or another.
Some people feared that strengthening
the national government with a kind of
counter attack against everything
that the revolution had meant.
And I want to give you a sense
of the flavor of this debate.
This is actually sort of pre convention
debate in which the states are figuring
out what to do. Um, and, and
I'm going local again, right?
I sort of tea to give you a sense of on
the ground reality during the revolution.
I went local and I talked about
the invasion of new haven's.
So for just a couple minutes here,
I want to go local again. Um,
and just give you a flavor of the debate
that was going on here in Connecticut.
After the Confederation Congress had
passed the resolution saying, okay,
we think that the states should select
delegates to send them to this convention
that's going to happen to
revise the articles, right?
They're not saying go destroy the
articles, but they are saying, okay,
revising the articles might be okay.
And once the Confederation
Congress makes that resolution,
the states now debate what
to do. So on May 12th, 17,
87,
the Connecticut legislature began
debating whether Connecticut should send
delegates to this proposed
convention to meet in Philadelphia.
That was coming up in a couple of what
coming up very soon in a matter of fact.
Um,
now most newspapers that reported on
what happened explicitly mentioned four
members of the Connecticut House who
came forward and declared that they were
opposed to sending
delegates to the convention.
All of these men were from small towns
and the Massachusetts border and all of
them in one way or another,
warned that sending a delegate to this
convention would endanger the liberties
and privileges of Americans.
So Alicia Fitch,
I love the fact that
their names are preserved.
Eliza Fitch say the convention might end
up a bridging the people's privileges
by creating some kind of a big unjust
centralized government that just wouldn't
consider in the individual person at all.
Daniel Perkins said that the men who
probably would be named as delegates to
this supposed convention would
probably be a bunch of rich,
aristocratic type men who
wouldn't understand or care
about the problems of the
average person in Connecticut.
Nevermind the poor of Connecticut.
So Perkins thought whatever
comes out of this convention,
it's bound to just ruin the poor.
It's going to be some weird
aristocratic decision.
Hosea Humphrey said that the convention
would probably somehow or other take
away the rights of Connecticut to
protest against things, to veto things.
Somehow or other,
it's going to be more centralized.
So Connecticut is going to
lose power in this equation.
And the fourth representative named
Abraham Granger was particularly straight
forward.
He said he knew that his constituents
didn't want delegates to be sent to this
convention and he represented them.
So first of all, there it was.
He had no choice. He had to just do
what they wanted him to do and say, no,
we should not send delegates
to the convention, but he
added, he agreed with them.
He actually thought that this
convention was a bad idea and he said,
stated specifically the reason why he
didn't like the whole idea of a convention
was probably it would end up creating a
monarchy and then we'd be right back to
where we were before.
So all of these men,
either directly or by implication,
clearly they're rejecting the idea that
the union or Connecticut is in such
horrible shape that something must
be done. We need a new government.
They're not traveling down that trail.
Granger actually in the
course of his remarks,
explicitly said that the Confederation
Congress had plenty of power.
The articles of confederation joined
with Connecticut's own constitution would
be just fine for the
people of Connecticut.
Implied in some of the comments of what
these men said is the idea that anything
could happen at this convention.
And obviously that's something I've talked
about before in this course as well,
but you can hear it underlying
a lot of their comments.
Who knows what's gonna come
out of this convention?
Anything could happen in
odds are whatever happens,
some fundamental American privileges
and rights are going to be taken away,
potentially buy a bunch of wealthy
aristocratic guys who are going to be the
ones standing in that room
in Philadelphia debating.
So they're basically imagining the
convention is going to be a bunch of
aristocrats who were going to subvert a
popular revolution and maybe even just
toss the new country right back into
a monarchical form of government.
So those are the four people who
at least the newspapers noted,
is really standing forth
against the convention.
Now of course the newspapers also
reported on nine men who spoke in favor of
attending the convention.
All of them were from commercial areas.
They all argued as you would expect
them to argue that the wellbeing of the
union and the wellbeing of the
state of Connecticut really,
really required a stronger
central government.
One of these nine even brought up an
embarrassing example of how powerless the
congress was that involves
Connecticut. He said, you know,
recently the Confederation Congress
asked the states, including Connecticut,
they requisitioned money from us and we
just decided we didn't feel like giving
them any and they couldn't do anything.
Remember like they asked us
for something and we said no,
and that was the end of that. Remember
guys are that, that's like a sign.
They don't have power because
we've watched them not have power.
When we just said no and he, this one
delegate went on to say, well, what about,
you know, think about it. That's not even
a problem. What about problems to come?
What if the Union begins to disintegrate?
What if, what if the union is invaded?
What would the confederation Congress
be able to do about problems like that?
So obvious.
Obviously in the end it's that kind of
an argument that wins out and Connecticut
voted to send delegates to the convention,
but obviously also not
without a real debate.
So even participating in the convention
was a big deal that required serious
debate and we haven't even
gotten to ratification yet.
As a matter of fact,
it was such a big deal that one state,
the state of Rhode Island, Rhode Island
is consistent throughout my entire glass.
But Eileen decided not to attend.
They actually just decided, no,
we're not participating.
We're not going.
So there were actually only 12 states
represented at the constitutional
convention. Rhode Island was a
holdout. So clearly so serious.
This one state is just not there.
So ultimately 12 states sent
delegates to the federal convention.
And I should add here,
just to not confuse you.
Sometimes I know I'm saying Federal
Convention and sometimes I'm saying
constitutional convention and there are
two ways of referring to the same thing.
Some historians say federal convention
because if you think about it,
every state could have a
constitutional convention,
but there can actually be maybe,
hopefully one federal convention.
But you can use either one.
You have my full permission to call it
either the constitutional convention or
the Federal Convention. So 12 states
sent delegates to the federal convention.
It met between May and
September of 1787 Rhode Island,
obviously, as I said, was not
there from those 12 states.
55 delegates attended
the convention in all.
And I suppose as you might expect,
overall, they were well educated men.
A lot of them were trained as lawyers.
A lot of them had experience
working in their state governments.
A good number of them had experienced
serving in either the continental
congresses or the Confederation Congress.
Now that said,
this doesn't mean that these were sort
of professional politicians sitting down
to write a constitution.
It's not as though they've prepared
their lobes for this this moment.
There are people who've been
involved in public life,
but they certainly have not been
training to sit down and create an entire
constitution for a whole country.
So despite that experience,
which I'm sure it served them well,
it does not suggest that they
actually are just ready to go.
They're not entirely sure
what's going to happen.
Now in some ways,
these delegates were kind of a self
selecting group because people who were
really dead set against the idea of
strengthening the national government
basically just didn't
go to the convention.
The problem with that strategy is on the
part of certainly the people who didn't
like this whole idea.
By not being there,
they made it easy to achieve a consensus
among the people who were there who
were a little more comfortable with
strengthening the national government.
Most of the people who were there
in one way or another ended up being
nationalists in some form.
And by nationalists I
actually don't just mean them,
James Madison's of the world.
It's a pretty wide spectrum of people
thinking about the fact that the national
government needs to be stronger.
And some of them, Hamilton, Madison,
Extremo of nationalists,
others not so much.
There's a pretty wide range and there
were some people at the convention, um,
who weren't even necessarily comfortable
with a great amount of increased
strength and did not end up
signing the constitution. So,
I'm not saying everyone
there is a firm nationalist,
but the really from I suppose you call
them at this moment to anti nationalists
didn't go for the most part.
So since they were not there,
it meant that there was a certain sort
of fundamental level of agreement at the
convention.
Now two of the delegates there were
particularly well known and to people who
were wondering what the heck
was going on in Philadelphia,
the presence of these two men made
a big difference. George Washington,
George Washington was there.
George Washington ended up
presiding over the convention,
which ended up being a
pretty important move. Um,
I've already talked in past lectures
about how he gained the trust of everybody
by continually surrendering power. Um,
so he's already a legend in his time.
Um,
but also he's a trusted leader.
So certainly having him there gave a
certain status to whatever was going on
meant that it was important and meant
that it was something that was being
treated responsibly because
George Washington had
invested it with his presence.
Benjamin Franklin also attended.
Again,
he's another man in this
period in American who had
an international reputation.
I've talked a little bit about
him as well and like Washington,
his presence there suggested that whatever
the heck was going on in Philadelphia,
it was important and it
had some major support.
The fact that these two men
were there was significant.
This is not the reason why he was there,
but I also am always happy when anyone
is anywhere who has a sense of humor.
So Franklin had one and it's always good
to have the guy with a sense of humor
at any large meeting of men
who have important things
to say. So for that reason,
I personally I'm happy to.
Benjamin Franklin was there. Now,
as I suggested on Tuesday,
Madison also played a major role and I
talked at the end of Tuesday's lecture
about his amazing notes that he recorded
partly thinking ahead to posterity.
His notes ended up being even more
significant because it was agreed at the
start of the convention that its
proceedings would be kept entirely secret.
The logic of that being that if it was
really, really kept entirely secret,
the people who were there would feel
free to really speak their minds.
They really wanted an open, full,
honest debate. So if people,
they're really believed that the public
would not know what they were saying,
someone for example,
it might feel free to stand up and say,
I personally would like a monarchy,
right?
If people thought that
public was watching,
no one's going to utter the m word
at the constitutional convention.
But if it's really secret,
the idea was it would allow for much
more open and free and potentially useful
debate. And there's
actually, um, I can't resist.
There's actually a story about the
secrecy of the Federal Convention,
which I will offer you,
cause it's also a George Washington.
He had another George Washington
story. I can't, I can't resist it. Um,
and it's actually,
it really is a way of showing
how important people at
the time considered the
idea of keeping the convention secret.
And it's from the notes of a delegate
who was there at the convention. And, um,
his name is William Pierce. And supposedly
at some point in the convention,
somebody found a page of notes about the
proceedings on the floor of the State
House and brought this up
to George Washington said
he know somebody lost these.
Okay.
So Washington takes the last notes and
at the end of that day's session he
stands up and he says, before we adjourn,
I'll read his precise words. Gentlemen,
I am sorry to find that some one member
of this body has been so neglectful of
the secrets of the convention
as to drop in the State House,
a copy of their proceedings,
which by accident was picked up
and delivered to me this morning.
I must entreat gentleman to be more
careful lest our premature speculations
disturb the public repos by
getting into the newspapers.
I know not whose paper it is.
And then he said,
but there it is.
And you sort of threw it down on the
table and added. Let Him who owns it,
take it. And according
to Pierce, he bowed,
picked up his hat and left the room
quote with a dignity so severe that every
person seemed alarmed. Okay.
The power of George Right?
He just sort of threw his weight
around and everyone's like, oh,
so pierce writes it immediately.
Everyone started like checking their
pockets and their notes like, oh,
I really hope those are not my notes.
Please don't be my notes.
Pearce says to his horror,
he discovered that his were lost.
So he kind of goes up to the front of the
room and he kind of peaks at the notes
and he's really relieved to
discover they're not mine. Okay.
That means his notes are lost
to people's notes are laws and pierce
then later says that he remembered,
Oh yeah,
I left them in my coat pocket in the
boarding house where I'm staying.
Uh, and he found them and got them
and hopefully everything was okay.
But I love the fact that, you know,
he's really relieved like, oh good.
At least those aren't my notes. There's
someone else who's really lost notes.
And according to Pierce,
Washington's reprimand was so off putting
that nobody ever claimed a piece of
paper. It will just stay there.
The scary piece of paper.
So obviously Madison's
notes are important also,
partly because this was very secret,
but of course as I hinted at the
very end of Tuesday's lecture,
what's particularly significant about
Madison's role in the convention,
it's his creation of a plan of government,
which ultimately is known
as the Virginia Plan.
Madison arrived at the convention
with a plan of government in hand,
so in a sense he immediately
set the terms of debate.
That was a really strategic move and I'll,
I'll add at this point that when you go
off into the future and have wonderful
jobs that in one way or another will
require you to have committee meetings and
various sorts.
The little lesson,
the life lesson that James Madison teaches
us here is if you set the agenda of
the meeting,
you set the terms of debate and you make
it much more likely that you win, right?
So remember James Madison down the
road and your professional lives,
he really does something very brilliant
strategically by walking in and
regardless of what is going to happen,
he doesn't know what's going to happen.
But he literally at least started
out by setting the terms of debate.
Now he may have devised
this plan of government,
but given that people already knew he
was sort of an extreme nationalist,
he wisely decided he would not stand up
and present this plan himself thinking
and probably rightly so, that if he
stood up and made a recommendation,
some people would immediately distrust
it as coming from some kind of an extreme
nationalist. So instead he
asked fellow Virginia delegate,
Edmund Randolph to present the plan.
And Randolph was popular and Randolph
was influential and unlike Madison,
Randolph was also a good public speaker.
So it was a wise choice.
So on May 29th just a few days
after the convention opened,
Randolph stood up and very diplomatically
and very gently open the subject of
altering the articles of confederation
though as you're about to see,
what he ends up suggesting
is not altering the articles.
So first he reviewed the weaknesses
of the articles and then he proposed a
series of resolutions.
The first one intended to just calm the
nervous down and sort of put people off
guard.
Nothing scary is happening here.
So he first says resolved that the
articles of confederation ought to be so
corrected and enlarged as to accomplish
the objects proposed by their
institution, namely common defense,
security of liberty and general welfare.
So Randolph there says he's proposing
to correct and enlarge the articles.
What followed that statement was a rather
radical plan of government that was
not a correction of the articles.
Instead,
it's pretty much proposed to demolish
the articles and create in their place a
strong national government that would be
grounded not on the individual states,
but instead on the people themselves.
This plan of government, the Virginia
plan is ultimately what it's called,
propose that the new government
would have three branches.
The first would be a
bicameral legislature.
The lower house would be
elected by the people.
The upper house would be selected by
the lower house from candidates named by
state legislatures.
The legislature would have the power to
nullify any state law contrary to the
constitution and representation.
As I mentioned in the lower house,
it's based on population.
The second branch was
the national executive
in the Virginia Plan.
The executive would have a qualified
veto over acts of Congress.
The plan didn't specify
whether the executive would
be a single individual or a
committee.
People talked about both.
The term of office
wasn't specified either.
And then obviously the third
branch was a national judiciary,
which would consist of one or more supreme
judges and some inferior courts to be
chosen by the national legislature
to hold off as during good behavior.
So I'll repeat that. Uh,
by camera legislature,
lower house elected by the people upper
house selected by the lower house from
candidates name by state legislatures.
The legislature can nullify any state
law that violates the constitution.
Representation is based on population.
Ranch too is the executive who has a
qualified veto over acts of Congress and
it's not specified one person, many
people, how long you should be an office.
And then the third
branch, the judiciary, um,
with one or more supreme judges chosen
by the national legislature holding
office during good behavior.
The Virginia Plan also included a flexible
amendment process and a procedure for
the admission of new states.
Now, as you can hear,
they're the basic outline of the final
constitution is kind of sitting there in
that plan and sort of fundamental frame
of what's coming in the next few months
is contained within the Virginia Plan.
So from the start of the convention,
things look a little auspicious for
the nationalists. And sure enough,
relatively early on in the convention,
there's a vote that a new national
government ought to be established and it
should have a supreme legislative
executive and judiciary branch.
Now that's a pretty major thing to decide.
It's a pretty major victory for people
who are really firm nationalists that,
okay,
the convention now has
committed to setting up a
supreme central government with
three branches and some more
nationalist victories followed.
So for example,
the confederation decided that the
executive would be one man after debating
this for a while,
and I'll talk a little bit more about
this towards the end of the lecture,
but they ultimately decided that one man
should be the executive and clearly in
a world where you're scared of centralized
power and thinking about kings,
that's a big decision.
And then they began to discuss
representation in the lower house of the
legislature. And I'm also going to come
back to representation in a few minutes,
but for now I'll simply state the obvious,
which is of course this debate broke down
as this debate always breaks down into
small states versus large states,
small states not liking the idea of having
representation be based on population.
Large states being perfectly
happy with that idea.
And small states had a good reason to
fear that their influence would just be
eliminated in some degree if
everything is based on population.
So on June 15th,
William Patterson of New
Jersey proposed his own plan,
which becomes the New Jersey
plants and other New Jersey moment,
the New Jersey plan.
Um,
and of course this is the plan that's
much more popular among small state
representatives.
The New Jersey plan suggested a one
house legislature in which obviously each
state would have one vote.
There would be a plural executive.
Um,
so an executive consisting of more than
one person who would be elected by the
Congress and the Supreme
Court chosen by the executive.
Now you can see how in some ways they're
a little vestiges of the articles
sitting there. In that plan,
there's a unicameral legislature.
Each state has one vote.
Even so,
even though this is
supposedly a less centralized,
less scary alternative to the
Virginia plan, it's still,
it is giving more power to the national
government. Then the articles had done
three days later,
someone successfully moved to postpone
consideration of the New Jersey plan and
instead consider simply revising the
articles. You can imagine the sort of,
uh, I went around the room. Oh No.
Now at this point,
Alexander Hamilton stood up and made
a dramatic move on June 18th he made,
but some describe as a six hour speech.
I can't imagine giving or listening to
a six hour speech in which he proposed
his plan of government, which as
you'll hear, is really, really,
really, really centralized
and national. Basically,
Hamilton's plant reduced the states
to administrative subdivisions.
Each would have a supreme executive
appointed by the national government,
a chief executive elected for life during
good behavior elected by electors who
are elected by electors who
were popularly chosen. Okay.
How removed can we get the people from
the process of choosing the executive
Hamilton also proposed a Senate chosen
for life during good behavior and an
executive with absolute veto power.
Okay.
That's like way out there and scary land.
You can imagine he gives a six hour
speech and that's what he comes up with.
He also,
during the speech praise,
the British government is the best
government on the face of the earth.
That's Hamilton,
so basically held it,
never lives down the speech
as a delicate later put it,
Hamilton's dramatic speech was praised
by everybody but supported by none.
It was like, thank you,
you can sit down now.
And it really did haunt him to the end
of his days because it seemed to be
eternal proof to anybody who
even vaguely didn't like him,
that he was really a monarchist at heart,
that he's just waiting for a chance to
convert the government into a monarchy
with a king at its head.
It's,
you can see why it was important to keep
the proceeding secret and you can see
how they did not get remain a secret for
very long. Right. Clearly they leaked.
If this,
if this is like the tin cans tied to
Hamilton's reputation for the rest of his
life, clearly it's leaking. Um, but
yeah, he never lived down that speech.
Now the question is why did he
stand up and give that speech?
Why did he stand up and praise the British
government is being the government on
the face of the earth?
Why did he propose this
extreme plan knowing how
people felt about some of these
ideas and there's disagreement.
There is not agreement on this. Um,
some historians assume that this was
a strategic move and then Hamilton was
trying to push the
convention past the week,
New Jersey plan or horror of horrors,
just revising the articles.
So according to the strategy,
Hamilton's plan would have looked so
extreme that the Virginia plan would look
really good in comparison.
And sure enough,
not that long after Hamilton speech
to the New Jersey plan is defeated.
So if this is why Hamilton did this,
you know, maybe you could say it worked.
However,
it's equally possible that Hamilton
wanted at least a moment to stand up and
offer his ideas and basically stayed,
okay, here's my plan of government.
Here's my little moment to shine.
Here's what I think we should be doing.
And I always feel, you know, I don't
know which of these is true or not true.
I think either one could be, or actually
both could be, but certainly the ladder,
um, theory has a little credence to it
only because you have to feel sorry for
Hamilton at the convention.
Here's this guy who for roughly
a decade has been saying,
we need a stronger national government.
He's one of the first,
he's one of the strongest. He's
consistent. He's out there.
This is like his message.
He finally gets a constitutional
convention and the other
two delegates from New
York do not like the idea of really
strengthening the national government very
much. And it's one state, one vote. So
basically his vote doesn't matter at all.
So this poor guy, he's like my
mission and my mission. Finally,
I'm here and I can't do
anything. I took aw, poor guy.
So it's possible that he did actually
stand up and say, okay, whatever,
here's what I would do,
what I would do,
and I'm going to announce
this and never live it down.
But here's what I would do during this,
what should be my prime moment.
So one reason or another,
who knows whether it was strategic or
cause he wanted his moment to lay out his
plan. The fact is that that night
after he gave the amazing speech,
he did meet with Madison and revise
Madison's notes so that they would be an
accurate reflection of what he said
just in case anyone didn't hear him.
Praise the British government is the
finest on the face of the earth. Okay,
so a little truth in both.
I think now I'm about to do a really,
really grave injustice
to the constitution. Um,
and so now is the moment when the
founders will be spinning in their graves
because I'm going to basically condense
my discussion of the constitution down
to three main issues.
Not because they're the only
issues that should be discussed,
but because certainly they
are all important issues.
And because they show
something about how concerns,
issues of the revolution continued to
play a role in American politics and in
American public life.
I apologize to all founders for
condensing the constitution down into near
minutes. Okay. The first issue that
I want to discuss is representation.
And the question here,
the obvious one population or one state,
one vote, small state, big state battle,
small stays are afraid
of having no influence,
which they continue to be afraid of.
This is not a battle that stops
once this decision is made,
it continues on and in one way or another
state through always sort of objecting.
You know,
there's a succession potential succession
plot by New England in the early 19th
century because they feel that they have
no influence. So this doesn't go away,
but certainly at this point
it's a real sticking point.
And ultimately a committee came up with
a solution which is known either as the
great compromise or the
Connecticut compromise.
And the reason why it's the Connecticut
compromise is cause it was proposed by
Connecticut delegate Roger Sherman, Roger
Sherman, he's a local boy yet again,
new haven appears on the map.
Roger Sherman lived in new haven and
actually you may have not have noticed it
because I'm probably the geek who
notices every historical plaque and the
universe. Um, but on the front
of the Union League cafe,
there actually is a
plaque to Roger Sherman.
It was his house like here was
his hose and here's what he did.
And we like Roger Sherman.
Um, so he's a new haven guy.
He's the guy who proposes the Connecticut
compromise and basically as you could
predict, the compromise
says representation in the
lower house will be based on
population and in the upper house,
one state,
one vote and that gets
passed on July 16th,
1787.
So representation first major issue,
second major issue.
Although in a way the problem with this
one is that it was not a major issue is
the question of slavery,
which clearly is linked to the
question of representation.
On August 8th northern states
attacked slavery on moral grounds.
And propose taking no account of
slaves as part of the population.
When allocating representation
in the national legislature.
Now obviously many southerners did not
like this idea and they defended slavery
on moral and economic grounds and they
were joined by some northerners who were
afraid that this issue was just
going to dissolve the union.
Gouverneur Morris of Pennsylvania
offers a nice sort of example of the
antislavery point of view.
I'll quote Maura's here upon what
principle is it that the slave shall be
computed in the representation?
Are they men then make them citizens
and let them vote or they property?
Why then is no other property included?
The houses in the city,
Philadelphia are worth more than all
the wretched slaves which cover the rice
swamps of South Carolina.
The admission of slaves
into the representation when
fairly explained comes to
this that the inhabitant of Georgia and
South Carolina who goes to the coast of
Africa and in defiance of the
most sacred laws of humanity,
terrorist has fellow creatures from their
dearest connections and damned them to
the most cruel bondage shall have more
votes in a government instituted for
protection of the rights of mankind
than the citizen of Pennsylvania or New
Jersey who views with a lot of
horror, so nefarious a practice. Wow.
That's a statement.
Strong statement.
Other side of the argument,
Charles Pinkney of South Carolina was
among those who stood up and tried to
justify slavery. An example
of his argument, he said,
if slavery be wrong,
it is justified by the example
of all the world in all ages,
one half of mankind had been slaves
and he cited Greece and Rome and other
ancient city states as well as sanctions
given to slavery in modern times.
So slavery is mentioned.
Slavery has its moment of debate,
but it is important to note. It was in
a sense a little more than a moment.
It only occupied a few days.
The issue was recognized to be a deal
breaker and when the delegates held up
their concern over slavery against
the idea of forming a union.
So basically when they saw that if they
really confront the issue of slavery,
they may never get a chance to
confront the issue of union.
They just decided not to
confront the issue at all.
And they memorialized their inability
to confront the issue in the document,
the Constitution itself and Article
One section nine of the constitution in
article one deals with Congress.
It states that quote,
the migration or importation of such
persons as any of the states now existing
shall think proper to admit shall not be
prohibited by the Congress prior to the
year 1,808 which basically says Congress
can't stop the slave trade before 1808
but look at how indirect that languages,
right? It doesn't say what I just said.
In very simple terms,
the importation of such persons as any
one of the states shall think proper to
admit, can there be a more indirect
way of referring to slavery?
They're tap dancing around this issue.
They're finding one way or another does
not to confront it. So the word slave,
the word slavery does not
appear in the constitution.
So basically faced with a pretty
fundamental moral problem,
the delegates to the constitutional
convention looked the other way and their
minds,
the union was too tenuous for anything
that's controversial to be addressed.
And this kind of sort of skipping out
or not confronting the issue cause it
seems like the deal breaker would be
seen again and again and again and
obviously eventually it becomes the deal
breaker and it does contribute to the
breaking of the Union.
Okay. So representation,
slavery to large issues under debate or
not under debate depending on which one
you're talking about.
The third issue I want to bring up concern
the national executive and obviously
that really had links to the revolution
revolution with a revolt against strong
centralized power in the form
of a monarchy and a monarch.
We've seen in previous lectures how
state constitutions that were created.
The 1770s really showed this ongoing
fear of tyrannical centralized executive
power. So we've seen when we were
looking at those state constitutions,
how more often than not,
legislatures were given more power
and governors were denied some power.
It's the same fear,
the same spirit,
it's charging the debate
during the convention.
So questions about the national
executive came up again and again.
How should he be elected by electors,
by electors chosen by state
legislatures, by state, governors,
by the national legislature,
by popular election.
How long should he serve?
Proposals range from two years
to life during good behavior.
The ultimate compromise suggested that
the president would serve for a four year
term and it didn't set a limit on how
often he could be reelected and he would
be elected by electors
in the separate states,
which reassured delegates who
were worried about state rights.
And each state could decide for
itself how to select its electors.
So if a state wanted to select electrics
by popular election, they could,
if a state wanted to have
their legislature pick
electrodes, they could, again,
they're sort of allowing the states to
come up with their own way of doing this.
States still have rights, um, but
still big scary issue of the executive.
So in a way that this,
all of these sort of compromises and
decisions end up creating an executive who
at least it felt like he was being
controlled in some way every four years by
having to face election.
Now in some ways considering everything
that I just said about being scared of
monarchy, King's America sort of
slipping right back into a monarchy,
this executive is granted a
surprising amount of power.
He's commander in chief of the armed
forces. He could carry on diplomacy,
he could recommend measures to Congress,
he could exercise a veto,
although obviously it could be overturned
by a two thirds vote in each house of
Congress.
Part of the reason for this amount of
trust in the executive was the idea of
checks and balances.
So people really actually did believe in
checks and balances and think that this
isn't a single executive sort of scary
and alone with no way to check his power,
that the constitution actually seems to
be kind of nicely balanced so that maybe
this person actually has some
restraints or some rains pulling him in.
Now obviously this is the, that I'm so,
I feel so bad and Hamilton, Madison,
I'm so sorry.
Um,
this is the most vast overgeneralization
of the constitution that I can almost
possibly imagine.
Um,
and I will come back to it because
we have to get it ratified,
which is part of what we're part of
what we're going to do on Tuesday. Um,
but in the interest of
time on September 16th,
1787, the constitution was
agreed upon on September 17th,
it was signed and sent to
the Confederation Congress
to pass along to the
individual so that they could ratify it.
And there needed to be nine states to
ratify the constitution for it to go into
effect.
And each state would have its own
ratifying convention to decide the issue.
So what we're going to be looking at,
at least at the beginning
of next Tuesday's lecture
is this second to debate,
which is what do we really
think about the constitution?
And part of what we'll be pulling from
that is what kind of a sort of status
check does it show us about what Americans
were thinking at the time, you know,
in what way do the different arguments
for and against tell us something about
America at that moment. So we'll see
this sort of highly contested debate.
We'll see states, um, that say
no and then say, yes, you know,
Rhode Island is still over here somewhere
waiting to see what happens. Um, and,
and it's really something that
people are watching closely.
I'll talk a little bit
more about this on Tuesday,
but I once again also
turned to Ezra styles. Um,
I'm basically always looking for
like something that makes this real.
So there's not just the document,
the debate, the constitutions.
So as freestyles diary,
I love as her style's diary,
so I'll mention it a
little bit more on Tuesday,
but he talks about what he thinks about
what's going on. And he talks about, um,
you know,
watching states ratify the constitution.
I'll mention some of that
as well cause it's again,
shows like one guy just kind of
responding to what's going on in a really
interesting way. I will stop there. I will
see you on Tuesday. Have a good weekend.